and a big okay on stage
singer wendy moton took a tumble during
tuesday's live episode of the voice
[Music]
wendy who is on team blake shelton had
just wrapped up her performance of i
can't help myself with blake and her
teammates lana scott and paris
winningham when she hit the ground while
walking off stage
and a big okay on stage
everybody all right
take a quick second we just had somebody
fall
cameras quickly cut away from wendy and
host carson daly attempted to let fans
know what was going on on stage
unfortunate
event from wendy moton
who is walking off and we hope she's
okay
and when the show came back from
commercial break wendy was right by
carson's side and assured viewers she
was a-ok
yes i'm okay i'm a little bruised but
you know what i'm still ready to go
ready to go on to next week that is
wendy lana and paris all made the top 10
and will be moving on to next week's
lives
couldn't be happier and blake he just
might be wendy's biggest fan this season
after landing the four-chair turn to his
team during the blind auditions he has
repeatedly said that she's the most
deserving singer he's ever coached it's
literally shocking in fact here's what
he said after her top 20 performance
earlier this season
hey wendy i'm going to say this i'm
probably going to catch a lot of heat
for it i don't care
i don't care
i've been doing this show for 21 seasons
now as a coach
and there is nobody that i want this
more
for
ever than you
you you deserve this of course the
competition this season is fierce
especially with new coach ariana grande
joining the show
it's the most fun i've ever had in my
whole life leading up to the season 21
premiere blake and fellow coaches kelly
clarkson and john legend all admitted
ari she's taking no prisoners
she's a threat she is hugely talented
hugely successful and has legions and
legions of fans that know how to use the
internet and vote
everything he just said
so we all knew it coming in i was
prepared i came with in battle armor
i'm prepared to be turned down it's just
being new there's so much to learn but i
feel like i just get to learn watching
them and it's been amazing
[Music]